we're told this table defines function f
alright for every X they give us the
corresponding f of X according to the
table is f even odd or neither so pause
this video and see if you can figure
that out on your own
alright now let's work on this together
so let's just remind ourselves the
definition of even and odd one
definition that we can think of is that
f of X if f of X is equal to F of
negative x then we are dealing with an
even function and if f of X is equal to
the negative of F of negative x or
another way of saying that if F of
negative x if F of negative x instead of
it being equal to f of X its equal to
negative f of X these last two are
equivalent that in these situations we
are dealing with an odd function and if
neither of these are true then we're
dealing with neither so what about
what's going on over here so let's see f
of negative 7 is equal to negative 1
what about F of the negative of negative
7 well that would be f of 7 and we see f
of 7 here is also equal to negative 1 so
at least in that case in that case if we
think of X is 7 f of X is equal to F of
negative x so it works for that it also
works for negative 3 & 3 f of 3 is equal
to F of negative 3 they're both equal to
2 and you can see and you can kind of
visualize in your head that we have this
symmetry around the y-axis and so this
looks like an even function so I will
circle that in let's do another example
so here once again the table defines
function f it's a different function f
is this function even odd or neither so
pause this video and try to think about
it alright
so let's just try a few examples so here
we have f of 5 is equal to 2 F of 5 is
equal to 2 what is f of negative five F
of negative 5
not only is it not equal to 2 it would
have to be equal to 2
this was an even function and it would
be equal to negative two if this was an
odd function but it's neither so we very
clearly see just looking at that data
point that this can neither be even nor
odd so I would say neither or neither
right over here let's do one more
example
once again the table defines function f
according to the table is it even odd or
neither pause the video again try to
answer it alright so actually let's just
start over here so we have f of 4 is
equal to negative 8 what is F of
negative 4 and the whole idea here is I
want to say okay if f of X is equal to
something what is F of negative x well
they luckily give us F of negative 4 it
is equal to 8 so it looks like it's not
equal to f of X its equal to the
negative of f of X this is equal to the
negative of f of 4 so on that data point
alone at least that data point satisfies
it being odd it's equal to the negative
of f of X but now let's try the other
points just to make sure so f of 1 is
equal to 5 what is F of negative 1 well
it is equal to negative 5 once again F
of negative x is equal to the negative
of f of X so that checks out and then F
of 0 well f of 0 is of course equal to 0
but of course if you say what is the
negative of f of if you say what the f
of negative of 0 well that's still F of
0 and then if you were to take the
negative of 0 that's still 0 so you
could view this this is consistent still
with being odd this you could view as
the negative of F of negative 0 which of
course is still going to be 0 so this
one is looking pretty good that it is
odd